let's make infinite chocolate  break the chocolate bar  rearrange the pieces and we have one  extra piece  don't believe it see it one more time  we rearrange the pieces we have the same  chocolate bar and one extra piece  how is this happening that we keep  making one extra square of chocolate  here's the trick explained  in this optical illusion chocolate is  very sneakily added to the pieces along  the diagonal  the amount that is added is exactly the  same area as this extra square of  chocolate  so unfortunately you can't create  infinite chocolate on the plus side we  know the rules of math and physics are  still intact